voilà pour ces témoignag recueilli donc
par Adrien Rivolier qui est avec nous
sur ce plateau ce soir et les questions
qu'on va se poser avec lui avec les
autres invités c'est évidemment celle de
savoir si ça marcherait mieux si on
était plus souple c'est ce que défend
notamment maître Cécile Madeline qui
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau et vous
avez entendu dans le documentaire au
contraire est qu'il faut durcir les lois
encore dirons certains ça fait trois
lois en 10 ans je crois sur sur
l'immigration pour quel résultat y y
a-t-il une vraie différence entre la
droite et la gauche dans ce dossier ou
bien est-ce qu'on se cont de faire d'un
côté comme de l'autre de l'affichage
parce que finalement la question est
trop sensible voilà ça c'est le débat
outre les deux invités que je vous ai
déjà présenter le sénateur UMP Roger
carucci qui est auteur de plusieurs
rapports parlementaires sur la question
rapports sénatoriaux bien évidemment
notamment sur le droit d'asile avec nous
également le policier Christophe Crépin
secrétaire national chargé de la
communication à l'une sa police et le
chercheur François gemen professeur de
sciences politiques notamment à
l'université de Versailles et
spécialiste des politiques migratoires
adriin et Velier d'abord ils ont été
faciles à convaincre parce que filmer
des gens qui finalement vivent pour pour
certains pour la plupart en France sous
le manteau c'est quand même curieux un
curieux pas à sauter non ça a été facile
de leur faire accepter la caméra alors
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que tous les
clients du cabinet d'avocat dans lequel
j'ai tourné ne sont pas sans papier il y
en a beaucoup qui ont des titres de
séjour et qui viennent pour d'autres
demandes pour aller un petit peu plus
loin peut-être demander la nationalité
française donc il y a pas forcément que
des S papi HM voilà bien sûr évidemment
c'était difficile de les convaincre euh
c'était pas l'acceptation était pas
immédiate visage découvert he c'est pour
ça que c'était une des conditions pour
moi j'ai fait beaucoup de films sur la
justice notamment la justice des mineurs
où j'avais pas le choix de voilà de ne
pas montrer les visages et pour ce film
c'était un choix de réalisation je je
voulais pouvoir redonner un visage aussi
humain à ces à ces personnes qu'on
appelle migré sans papier on sait plus
trop comment on les appelle le débat sur
l'immigration depuis une quarantaine
d'années oui euh partout dans les
discussions politiques dans les médias
et cetera et j'avais envie par ce film
de redonner un visage humain à ces
gens-là et redonner plusieurs visages
aussi parce que toutes les histoires
sont très différent il y a autant de de
problématiqu juridiqu que d'histoire et
de parcours de vie humain ils ont tous
des raisons très singulières de venir
sur notre territoire et je crois que
c'était important à l'heure actuelle de
de les montrer à visage découvert qui
raconte à l'avocat par l'interm de
l'avocat leur parcours de vie le
parcours du combattant parce qu'il faut
le dire c'est le cas euh qu'ils ont dû
entreprendre pour arriver sur le
territoire parfis en sachant qu'ils
serait en situation illégale sur le
territoire français ils connaissent nos
lois ils connaissent nos textes ils
connaissent leurs
droits bien s'ils viennent voir un
avocat c'est qu'ils les connaissent pas
de manière intégrale évidemment ou mais
est-ce qu'ils ont été brifé je pense
qu'il ils connaissent le droit des
étrangers de manière beaucoup plus
approfondie que la plupart d'entre nous
nous euh ça c'est une c'est une réalité
mais parfois ils le connaissent mal
c'est parfois il y a il y a des réalités
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde on
parle très souvent des passeurs oui bien
sûr les passeurs existent oui bien sûr
les passeurs exploitent euh les
situations de fragilité de certains
étrangers et réclam des sommes d'argent
abominables et leur transmettent un
droit qui est absolument faux donc
parfois ils viennent très souvent avec
des idées fausses sur le droit mais
quand même euh bah le parcours du
combattant fait qu'ils ont été obligés
de plonger dans ils ont été obligés de
plonger c'est il y a un droit en France
et finalement ça peut jouer pour
moi je crois que je je sais pas si l' je
crois pas que l'objectif pour eux de
venir en France de se dire voà je viens
en France parce que le droit est facile
pour moi je crois qu'à un moment donné
il y a on va rejoindre la famille
peut-être à un moment donné on décide de
quitter son pays parce qu'on est
vraiment en grande grande difficulté il
y a toujours une bonne raison très
honnêtement de venir ici on entend on
entend beaucoup de choses on vient on
vient profiter du système profiter des
allocations profiter de tout un tas de
de droits en réalité un sans papier qui
arrive sur le territoire français par
exemple n'a pas le droit au RSA n'a pas
le droit aux allocations familiales il a
le droit à aide médicale bon mais ça
c'est quand même le
droit oui mais c'est quand même un petit
peu c'est peut-être une question de de
droit humain de de pouvoir subvenir au
besoins de santé de d'un individu quel
qu'il soit et où qu'il soit à la fin de
votre documentaire on a le sentiment que
tout le monde gagne finalement pardon je
vais le dire brutalement que la France
ne choisit pas ses étr
voilà qu'on peut pas choisir dans ce
film il y a SEP cas dans ce film il y a
SEP
personnages il y a pas cette victoire en
réalité si vous regardez bien ce couple
qui qui est défendu par Maître Madeline
au tribunal administratif effectivement
la personne indienne sort du centre de
rétention mais sa situation n'est
absolument pas régularisée la la
personne qui est apatride qui
c'està-dire qui est sous menace
d'expulsion du territoire français
c'està-dire que la justice décide de
l'expulser mais il n'a pas de patrie
dans laquelle aller c'est ce geéorgien
ce georgien d'origine casier judiciaire
coupable de rébellion AG son cas est
assez spectaculaire faut bien le dire
oui mais est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une
victoire les deux personnes qui sont en
fin du film les deux les deux
personnages on les revoit pas est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'on a gagné je crois pas
que le film montre une vision angélique
de la de la question et du travail des
avocats je pense que voilà j'ai pas j'ai
pas fait un tri d'affaires gagné je n'ai
pas choisi que des affaires gagnées je
n'ai pas choisi que parce qu'on je
craignais forcément qu'on me dise oui
mais Adrien tu as une vision angélique
du sujet tu vas montrer que des
situation où on gagne que des situations
de de personnes qui sont dans qui se
comportent parfaitement bien et c'est le
cas pour 99 99 % des des clients mais la
personne Georgienne en question par
exemple bon voilà effectivement il a eu
des comportements tout à fait
contestables je pense que il en est où
maîre Madeline à ma connaissance
toujours dans la même situation
c'est-à-dire que sa situation
régularisation est bloquée parce que le
casier judiciaire effectivement empêche
la préfecture de la régulariser mais
comme il est il est georgien d'origine
yéside ou yzidi on en parle beaucoup en
ce moment avec les massacres qu'il y a
en Syrie notamment contre les yeszidis
effectivement c'est une minorité qui est
peu reconnue et là la Georgie a toujours
dit pour moi il n'est pas il n'est pas
ressorti sint- georgien donc on est
effectivement comme le dit Adrien
Rivolier face à une situation de faitete
d'apatridi même si elle est pas reconnue
juridiquement et face à quelqu'un qui de
toute façon n'est pas éloigné et n'est
pas régularisé et ça c'est très
criminogène ce qui est très frapp
dans le documentaire et sans doute dans
la situation qu'elle révèle et que vous
vivez vous tous les jours au cabinet à
rouan Roger KCI c'est que finalement
chaque cas pris individuellement on a
envie de dire oui ça se plaide
oui mais alors vous pourriez faire ça
pour 10 millions de personnes parce que
si vous voulez qu'on fasse le tour du
monde des massacres des difficultés ou
des problèmes économiques des gens très
pauvrees des gens dans la misère
quasiment je reprendrai pas un ancien
président de la République de gauche qui
dis disait la France ne veut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
au Premier
ministre on pas un président c'est pas
mais euh mais la la réalité c'est que on
a des textes mal ficelés alors on attend
un prochain texte sur l'immigration et
le droit d'asile on va voir s'il est
mieux ficelé et euh la situation en
France est devenue insupportable et
chacun le comprend nous n'avons plus les
moyens nous n'avons plus la capacité de
faire comme si tout était possible alors
arrive un moment où les situations
individuelles font toujours ou de la
peine ou de l'émotion et c'est normal et
en même temps quand vous dites par
exemple que l'aide médicale d'État créée
en 2000- 200001 coûtait à l'époque 75
million d'euros 750 millions d'euros
cette année probablement 1 milliard
l'année prochaine à un
moment on peut aussi se demander si les
Français en général pas seulement la
classe politique ou les parlementaires
ou je ne sais qui si les Français en
général peuvent continuer d'accepter
l'idée qu'au nom de
l'émotion normale quand on voit le
documentaire est-ce que au nom de cette
émotion on a encore dans ce pays la
capacité de
payer question est-ceon pourrait se
poser la question aussi de savoir est-ce
que
laimmigration apporte des richesses en
France a des rapports làdessus monsieur
Gman je pense que voà vous avez
certainement des informations sur sur le
sujet j'en ai lu notamment dans un
article de L'Express qui pas forcément
journal réputé à gauche en tout cas qui
milite pour la cause forcément de des
personnes étrangères ou sans papier et
qui avait développé un dossier très très
complet je je pourrais pas citer les
sources mais qui qui expliquait que il y
a énormément de richesse qui proviennent
de cette population qui vient
s'installer sur le sur le territoire des
métiers qui sont occupés par ces
personnes-là qui ne seraient occupés par
personne d'autre et ça tout le monde le
sait donc je pense que qu ils sont s
papier je pense bien sûr que si quand
ils sont sans papier
fa femmes de mén par des hommes poliques
de l'immigration David Cameron a
démission quelques mois parce que
d'ouvrage était en situation régulière
grandne les Anglais par est certain que
les Français sont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus vertuueux que les anglais
alors on a posé le débat et je crois que
c'est très clair merci beaucoup Adrien
Rivolier en tout cas pour pour ces
témoignages qui vont continuer à
alimenter notre discussion je voudrais
qu'on réécoute Mohamad il est sans
papier lui il est sans papier on peut
dire ça comme ça il comprend pas bien
pourquoi les policiers continuent à
l'arrêter dit-il en moyenne une fois par
mois parce que lui l'affirme il est là
depuis des années il vous encerit la
semaine dernière ouais bah oui mais
c'est quoi alors le 15 mai 2013 ça c'est
prochaine fois non ah oui avant une fois
une fois avant c'est pas la première
fois qu'on vous arrête beaucoup fois
beaucoup chaque mois donc on vous arrête
aussi le 13 mai 2013 ouais on vous
arrête tous les mois tous les mois une
fois je sais pas c'est quoi ça ils ont
toujours pas réussi rvoy c'est pas
criminal c'est pas rien des choses droit
gauche mais c'est pas une question mais
monsieur Mohamad c'est pas une question
d'être criminel ou pas mais vous avez
pas de
papier c'est normal qu'on contrôle c'est
pas parce qu'on vous considère comme un
criminel he c'est juste parce que vous
avez pas de
papier donc conclusion conclusion il est
pas dans le cadre de la circulaire pour
l'instant il n'a pas encore les 10 ans
de séjour il est sous le coup d'une
d'une mesure d'éloignement c'est soit il
échappe à la mesure d'éloignement il se
cache un certain
temps là on pourra envisager
éventuellement de réécrire au préfet
quand il aura 10 ans de séjour au mois
de juin 2014 mais pas tout de suite il a
pas loi avec le contrat travail là ça
fait 5 ans je viens de vous dire que non
je vous l'ai expliquer monsieur oui on
va pas refaire rendez-vous
là je veux pas vous dire un truc pour
vous faire plaisir je vais vous dire ce
que c'est sa
situation voilà pour cette situation il
il il a été régulariséin ce sans papier
n'est plus un S papier c'est donc
aujourd'hui un étranger en situation
régulière en France Christophe crpin
quand même parce que la situation ne
fait pas hausser les sourcils que de
Roger kuchci vous pouvez m'expliquer
comment on peut arrêter un
homme une fois par mois en moyenne
dit-il et le retrouver libre dans le
cabinet de son avocat parce que à chaque
fois on lui donne les injonctions pour
quitter le territoire ce qu'il ne fait
pas et au bout d'un certain temps il il
se fait régular
par ses avocats c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne pardonnez-moi ça veut dire
que quand un policier interpelle on dit
ça comme ça contrôle contrôle un
fonctionnaire de police fait un contrôle
d'identité sur une
personne qui s'aperçoit que cette
personne doit quitter le territoire on
lui donne une injonction pour quitter le
territoire un papier on lui demande de
quitter le territoire sous un délai de X
temps et beaucoup de migrants ne veulent
pas quitter le territoire et se font
encore encore par si je comprends bien
il il reçoit un papier il sort du
commissariat quelques semaines plus tard
peu importe un mois ou
pas comprend mais il se fait contrôler à
nouveau à nouveau il va au commissariat
on lui en met une injonction il quitte
le territoire c'est comme ça que ça se
passe alors sur ce cas précis très
honnêtement je ne peux pas vous
expliquer mais de manière générale ça se
passe pas de manière aussi simple que ça
hein un étranger qui est en situation
irrégulière et qui va se faire contrôler
va d'abord être placé en retenu ça c'est
une nouvelle procédure qui a une garde à
vue spéciale sans papier h donc il va
êtreenu pendant 20h comme ça sur le
champ pour qu'on établiss sa situation
c'est le temps qui est donné à la
préfecture pour prre les arrêtés qui
s'imposent ensuite le sans papier il va
pas ressortir libre il va se retrouver
au centre de rétention aujourd'hui on
peut être retenu pendant 45 jours dans
une espèce de prison qui ne dit pas son
mot ça n'est pas une prison c'est un
centre de rétention c'est exactement la
même chose et effectivement s'il a la
chance de pouvoir trouver un avocat
qu'il défend s'il a accès au juges parce
que il y a des éloignements qui se font
sans accès au juges donc il faut savoir
qu'encore une fois les cas qu'on voit
dans le film forcément c'est les gens
qui sont allés jusqu'aux avocats mais
tout le monde n'a pas tout le monde n'a
pas cette chance là effectivement si il
peut accéder à un juge et que il y a un
non respect de la loi alors il sera
libéré mais quand un tribunal
administratif annule une mesure
d'éloignement c'est parce qu'il y a des
raisons juridiques de les annuler des
raisons sur le fond parce que
éventuellement la personne est menacée
ou a des attaches familiales ou c'est
parce qu'il y a eu un non respect de la
loi vis de procédure des vises de
procédure mais encore une fois n tienne
qu'au service de police ou de préfet de
respecter les procédures les juges font
leur travail j'entends il arrive à vos
collègues de retomber sur les mêmes
personnes comme ça de manière régulireou
ça arrive ça arrive d'une manière
récurrente oui oui bien sûr mais la
vérité c'est que combien et quel est le
pourcentage des mesures d'éloignement
décidé par la justice qui sont
réellement exécuté donc le problème il
est là c'est que en réalité sur le
territoire national je ne sais pas
exactement combien il y a de de de gens
sans papier dans les centres de
rétention mais vous en avez 10 fois plus
20 fois plus dans entre 300000 et
400000 oui sur le territoire sur le
territoire il y en a 400000 mais il y en
a beaucoup qui ont qui ont fait l'objet
d'une mesure d'éloignement qui avait un
certain délai pour quitter le territoire
national et qui ne l'ont pas fait à
partir de là que les policiers tombent
sur des gens sans papier entre
guillemets et en situation irrégulière
sur le territoire national c'est la
règle assez cour dans quel cas on
raccompagne à la frontière la fameuse
reconduite au
frontières situation irrégulière la S du
CRE c'est la
théorie la
théorie vous AZ cité des chiffres tout à
l'heure ça coûte quand même Chac année
au budget deéat 800 millions d'euros
cette affaire vous avez parlé du budget
de l'emdical d'État 750 millions de ton
ça coûte encore plus ch la politique de
répression coûte encore plus cher alors
je comprends que je comprends que les
téléspect je comprends que les
téléspectateurs puissent être un peu
choqués il voit cette affaire ce type
qui se balade dans la nature qui se fait
interpeller par la police qui reçoit une
injonction de quitter le territoire qui
va trouver un bon avocat et puis qui
parvient à se faire régulariser
présenter comme ça ça l'air un peu
choquant mais en réalité pourquoi est-ce
que tous ces gens qui sont sous ordre de
quitter le territoire qui sont sans
papier pourquoi est-ce qu'ils se
retrouvent dans ces situations ce sont
souvent des gens qui sont arrivés en
France légalement qui sont arrivés avec
des papiers un visa de tourisme un visa
d'étudiant et cetera pas celui-là mais
on va pas on va pas sematiser une
personne c'est pas le sujet oui oui et
qui en fait vont pouvoir en France
trouver du boulot qui vont poursuivre
des études qui vont parfois fonder une
famille et qui par la suite vont se
retrouver dans une situation irrégulière
ils vont tomber dans l'irrégularités
mais à ce moment-là pour eux ça devient
très difficile de quitter le territoire
parce qu'ils ont toute une vie sociale
en France qu'ils ont des attaches en
France et alors ça crée des situations
impossible
pour parce que je veux c'est important
de bien comprendre vous êtes en train de
me dire en gros que la plupart des sans
papers aujourd'hui sont des gens qui
sont rentrés de manière régulière en
absolument absolument plus de 90 % pard
par pard pardon on peut pas laisser dire
ça par que je comprends que ce soit la
vision certain nom en quand vous rentrez
en France avec un visa étudiant ou avec
un un un visa de touriste vous rentrez
légalement mais vous nêtes pas censé
rester sur le territoire national pour
il fonder une famille trouver un emploi
et
Cera ce que je qu'il rentre légalement
et pu qu'il tombe dansirrégular non non
non non non non non non la manière dont
vous le dites on a le sentiment que
c'est l'état absolument oppressif non
pas du tout la réalité c'est que il
rentre dans l'illégalité à partir du
moment oùétant rentré qu'avec un visa de
tourisme ou d'étud ils font comme si ils
avaient évidemment la capacité de
trouver un emploi de fonder une famille
et tout c'est pas le cas quand un
français va dans certains pays du monde
avec un visa d'étudiant ou visa de
tourisme je vous garantis qu'au terme
des études ou au terme du du séjour
touristique ils repartent je peux vous
dire que pour m'occuper des Français
aussi qui partent à l'étranger il y a
énormément de Français qui fondent des
familles à l'étranger vous savez il se
pose des problèmes aussi non non mais il
y en a il y a certainement autant de
Français qui se marient à l'étranger que
d'étrangers qui se mari en France
d'accord d' je voudrais qu'on arrive à
établir des faits c'est vous avez le
droit de vous évidemment de vous de vous
attraper les uns les autres et c'est
tout l'intérêt d'un débat mais quand
même essayons de revenir au au fait
reconduite aux frontières je vis revenir
là est-ce qu'il y en avait plus est-ce
qu'il y en avait moins quand Nicolas
Sarkozi était au pouvoir par exemple
parce que on a entendu brissortefeu
scandé année après année le chiffre des
reconduites aux frontières comme l'un
des succès de sa politique est-ce qu'il
y en a moins aujourd'hui non un peu plus
un pe plus socialiste expulse un peu
plus que le gouvernement Nicolas Sarkozi
en 2013 non si si j'ai pas de chiffre
précis
on est autour de 30000 on est autour
de00 dans ce concours un peuthétique de
qui expulse peux parler du terrain et je
peux vous dire que les centres de
rétention il y a autant de monde dans
les centres de rétention et que
véritablement moi je le dis vraiment
sans clivage politique moi je ne vois
pas de différence en tout cas dans la
façon de traiter l'immigration
irrégulière en France depuis le
changement de majorité il y a eu des
mesures quand même prises il a il y a eu
des circulaires de régularisation dont
on pourrait discuter avec des critères
extrêmement restrictifs mais sur la
pratique puisque vous parlez de
l'éloignement des étrangers en situation
régulière il y a absolument pas de
souplesse aujourd'hui un policier qui
arrête un S papier va le conduire en
centre de rétention donc ça il y a pas
de nouveauté et surtout ce qu'on voit je
je vais dire les les choses brutalement
de manière un peu caricaturale la gauche
n'est pas laxiste vis-à-vis des
étrangers en tout cas euh cette gauche
là non ça c'est certain non non cette
gauche là manuel Val vouis dire
aujourd'hui c'est François hand le
président de la République absolument
pas non non mais très honnêtement moi
j'ai constaté même sur certains points
un durcissement par rapport à ce que
j'avais pu connaître avant par exemple
par exemple en fait on fait des
opérations à certains moment pour
trouver des sans papiers ça monsieur de
la police va pouvoir nous expliquer
comment ça fonctionne mais il y a
parfois des réquisitions de procureur de
la République qui disent dans tel
endroit on va contrôler tout le monde
alors entre parenthèses on cherche
toujours les mêmes étrangers hein soit
ceux qui sont en famille soit ceux qui
travaillent ce qui est un petit peu
paradoxal parce que de recherche
particuli alors si je peux vous assurer
que si quand on se met sur les péages
d'autoroute à 6h ou 7h du matin et qu'on
arrête que les camionnettes de chantier
je suis désolé on arrête effectivement
les sans papiers qui travaillent ça
c'est une évidence donc qui travaille au
noir d'ailleurs ou déclarer le but c'est
deutter finement contre certain pour
l'étatm pour l'ét par exemple on cherche
spécifiquement moi je dis qu'on cherche
spécifiquement les étrangers notamment
qui travaillent parce que ce sont ceux
qui sont les plus faciles à attraper
mais donc pour en revenir à ces
réquisitions donc qui viennent du
procureur de la République et qui
viennent dire dans tel endroit on va
contrôler tout le monde alors avant on
disait on cherche les 100 papier
maintenant comme c'est dépénalisé on
cherche autre chose mais en réalité on
contrôle les personnes qui ont l'air
d'être origine d'origine étrangère bien
par exemple j'ai vu il y a un an quelque
chose que qui était complètement inédit
pour moi des réquisitions de contrôle
dans les trains et c'est vrai que c'est
un peu si vous voulez c'est un peu
choquant dans l'idée c'està-dire que il
y a des policiers qui arrivent dans les
rames de train qui sont en route on met
un policier au début du wagon un
policier à la fin du wagon et on
contrôle absolument tout le monde y
compris les gens qui ont des billets de
train et là c'est vraiment la
sourissière si vous
voulezétrangeru il y a une rumeur qui a
couru qui a dit qu'il y avait également
des contrôles il y a une rumeur qui a
couru qui qui a dit qu'il y avait
également des des contrôles au devant
les préfectures ou par définition on
vient faire la C a plus que des
contrôles il y a des arrestations dans
les préfecture c'est-à-dire queil y a ce
qu'on appelle des non non non non il y a
ce qu'on appelle des convocations pièg
alors heureusement les juges garant des
libertés individuelles annule ces
procédures mais je peux vous assurer
qu'il y a des étrangers qu'on convoque
en préfecture en leur laissant croire
qu'on va leur donner un titre de séjour
et en réalité on leur dit monsieur vous
voulez des papiers ok très bien vous
asseyez là tranquillement on va vous
préparer votre carte et là on passe un
pe coup de fil il y a deux policiers qui
arrivent et qui interpellent les gens
qui essayent de sortir de la
clandestinité Christophe crpin il y a
une politique du chiffre attende par je
vis poser ma question avant la réponse
si c'est possible est-ce qu'il y a une
politique du chiffre comme vous avez dit
votre syndicat a dit qu'il y en avait
une du temps de Nicolas Sarkozi par
exemple de l'intéeur chiffré quand
monsieur Val a pris les règnes du
ministère de l'Intérieur ont été abolis
néanmoins il faut quand même pas
se mentir il il y a quand même une
politique quantifiée pourquoi parce que
les primes au résultat pour les chefs de
service est toujours basé sur les
résultats qu'obtiennent les gardiens de
la paix sur le terrain en matière
d'étranger en matière générale en
matière générale et donc la politique la
politique migratoire du gouvernement
actuel n'a pas changé sur les autres
politiques il faut en matière de de
migration avoir une politique constante
ce qui est le cas avec l'actuel ministre
de l'Intérieur l'ancien ministre de
l'Intérieur et on ne peut que se faister
que la justice traite cas par cas chaque
étranger et
donne gouvernement la possibilité à
chaque individu même s'il est en
situation irrégulière de pouvoir se
défendre à l'aide d'avocat moi je je ne
vois pas de différence moi je suis à
politique je vois pas de différence sous
l'ancien sous le nouveau s la nouvelle
monture mais je sais que les droits des
étrangers sont respectés et moi je peux
vous parler pour le connaître de
personnes qui ne veulent pas quitter le
territoire et qui emploi tous les
stratagènes possibles il faut bien que
vos auditeurs voient ça quand même hein
c'est quand même oui alors certains
disent certains disent la loi est trop
compliquée en France vous allez entendre
cette cet homme euh naturalisé français
il est chef d'entreprise je le précise
parce que le réalisateur me l'a soufflé
à l'oreille tout à l'heure il emploie 25
personnes entreprise d'informatique il
veut maintenant faire venir ses deux
filles en France comme c'est compliqué
il le dit tout net il fera mais sous le
manteau moi j'ai une solution alors
allez-y c'est ma solution c'est parce
que comme eux ils veulent me compliquer
de leur côté
euh vous savez quand ils disent que il y
a des entrées des gens clandestinement
c'est parce que eux-mêmees ils
compliquent les choses ouais bon et là
moi j'ai dit ah vous allez faire entrer
vos filles oui je vais le faire rentrer
d'une manière ou d'une autre et à la fin
ils vont se retrouver ici et comme ça on
va exhiber les papiers hein parce que
moi j'ai voulu le faire honnêtement et
il me complique moi j'iraai de de
l'autre côté vous dites Cécile Madeline
dans le dans le documentaire d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure que finalement c'est
notre fermeté c'est un peu notre
bureaucratie qui condamne les étrangers
à passer en situation irrégulière en
tout cas à par sortir que ce serait plus
fluide si on était pas si dur dans ce
cas-là ce cas-là il est tout à fait
typique voilà un homme qui est arrivé en
France depuis de nombreuses années qui
est naturalisé français qui est
extrêmement bien
la seule chose c'est que c'est un homme
qui vient d'un pays en guerre quand il a
quand il a il est arrivé en France il
n'avait plus de nouvelles de ces deux
filles qui étaient à ce moment petite
dont il pensaient très qu'elles avaient
été perdu pendant la guerre ou
éventuellement décédé donc comme ils
n'avaient pas leurs actes de naissance
qu' n'avaient pas parlé d'ell elles
n'ont pas été naturalisé en même temps
que lui il retrouve la trace de ses
filles et il demande des visas puisque
légalement on permet quand même il est
français donc on permet aux enfants de
français de pouvoir venir en France
jusque là je pense que c'est acceptable
je regarde monsieur sénateur je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en pense mais semble quand
même qu'aujourd'hui ça me semble quand
même normal qu'un Français a le droit de
faire venir ses enfants bon la seule
chose c'est qu'effectivement j'explique
à ce client que comme il n'a pas parlé
de ses enfants au moment de sa
naturalisation de deux choses une soit
on dira c'est pas vrai ce sont pas vos
filles soit on va lui retirer sa
naturalisation donc je lui explique ça
il est venu me consulter je lui explique
qu'effectivement il est complètement
pris dans un étau qui pourra toujours
expliquer qu'il savait pas qu'elles
étaient encore en vie mais qu'on ne va
pas le croire parce qu'il y a quand même
une suspicion généralis contre les
étrangers notamment l'état civil c'est
très clair on a toujours l'impression
qu'une personne d'origine africaine va
frauder hein que les enfants ne sont pas
ses vrais enfants enfin je vous passe
tous les détails des débats qu'on avait
eu vous vous rappelez on parlait des
tests ADN pour les gens qui venaient
d'Afrique notamment c'est tout à fait
dans la lignée de cela et c'est vrai que
j'explique au clients qu'il est dans une
sourissière que soit on lui dira non
pour ses enfants soit on va lui retirer
la nationalité française je me contente
de donner ce conseil après effectivement
vous voyez la réponse qu' fait c'est pas
moi qui suè et on entend bien qu'il a
disparu des clients de votre cabinet que
vous n'avez plus de ces nouvelles depis
on sa à mon avis très vraiment je ne
sais pas ce qu' a fait monsieur ce
monsieur mais il est fort probable qu'il
n'it rien fait du tout et que ces filles
soient malheureusement pour elle
toujours en Afrique sans leur père Roger
KCI vous PL des coupables est-ce qu'il
arrive que la loi crée des situations
d'illégalité c'est quand même sac par
attende attendez la loi qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs de gauche ou droite c'est la
loi quand on m'explique que on est trop
dur parce que la police contrôle des
gens qui sont sous le coup d'une
expulsion et qui ne sont pas partis
pardon de vous dire c'est la loi euh
dans la République chacun ne fait pas ce
qu'il veut comme il veut on nentre pas
dans le pays n'importe comment et on
n'en sort pas non plus n'importe comment
d'ailleurs mais dans le cas précis si je
crois comprendre il a obtenu sa
naturalisation d'autant plus facilement
probablement il a dit qu'il était seul
alors c'est vrai que je peux comprendre
j'en sais rien je connais pas le cas que
l'administration quand vous arrivez
comme le dit maître ici présent vous dit
attendez monsieur il y a quelques an
anné dans votre dossier de
naturalisation Vous n'aviez pas d'enfant
parce qu'il a sûrement pas dit j'ai deux
filles je sais pas où elles sont il a dû
ne pas en parler du
toutz pas non mais est-ce que est-ce
qu'il arrive que la loi soit tellement
compliquée qu'elle crée des situation
entendu que les lois sont compliqué les
lois sont forcément compliquées parce
que les situations sont compliquées
parce queentre le droit d'asile
l'immigration économique l'immigration
clandestine tout est compliqué
simplement un pays une république un
état de droit est censé se à la fois
protéger ses citoyens et faire en sorte
que l'accueil quand il y a un accueil
soit digne de ce nom on ne peut pas non
plus raconte unu des histoires parce que
d'un côté on dit si vous respectez la
loi vous pourrez venir ou pas et puis si
vous respectez pas la loi et ben vous
disparaîtrez mais vous resterez sur le
territoire mais on Nura pas dit que vous
pouvez
rester moi je dis si vous ne respectez
pas la loi s'il y a une décision
judiciaire comme quoi il faut quitter le
TER teritoire le rôle de la police c'est
de faire en sorte que la personne quitte
le territoire je suis désolé de dire la
loi doit être appqué tout le M l'entend
la question c'est de savoir si les lois
successives parce que il y a eu combien
TR lois en 10 ans c'est ça il y en a
même eu 5 en 15 est- est-ce qu'elle rend
plus efficace la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale sans doute une
question que télpectateur absolument pas
l'immigration illégale continue
d'augmenter en France comme en Europe
pourquoi parce que partout en Europe on
a mis en place des politiques
migratoires de plus en plus répressiv on
ESS de faire de plus en plus les portes
en croyant qu'en fermant les portes on
allait stopper l'afflux de migrants la
réalité c'est que ça ne marche pas si on
fait une politique migratoire plus
répressive ça n'empêche pas les gens de
venir simplement ça le fait venir dans
des conditions moins légales et dans des
conditions plus dangereuses vous vous
supprimeriez les les complexités les
complications la
fermeté droit est un droit fondamental
et que chacun a le droit de s'établir
dans le pays qu'il souhaite donc ma
position est très claire je suis
favorable à l'ouvert un référendum en
France juste pour
moi je voudrais 95% bien sûr il y a
plein de gens qui sont aussi pour la
peine de mort si vous faites un
référendum sur la peine de mort
onétablir discutons discutons de manière
raisonnable discutons de manière
raisonnable un élément quand même qui
pour moi est important je suis pas
spécialement d'accord tout ce qui est
législatif ça c'est votre domaine je le
respecte je vous laisse faire par contre
il faut quand même voir une chose ce que
ces gens-là pour moi ce sont quelquefois
des victimes d'un système qui est très
clair et très net ce sont des
criminalités organisées qui font croire
à ces gens que ça avec l'Eldorado en
Europe et on a affaire à des gens qui
viennent chez nous avec des passeurs et
ça pour moi c'est une criminalité
organisée et c'est comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir lutter efficacement en luttant
contre ces réseaux contre ces gens qui
traitent les humains voilà ça c'est vrai
ça je voulais je voulaisor a des succès
en la matière mais bien sûr qu'on a des
succès on a des on a des collègues qui
font qui passent quasiment toute leur
carrière à lutter contre ce crime
organisé c'est un crime organisé on
laisse des gens en plein milieu de la
mer et on s'en va on laisse des gens à
Calais et puis on les laisse comme
ça donc c'est réseau de passeur criminel
c'est aujourd'hui le trème business le
plus rémateur du monde derrière la
drogue et le trafic d'armes c'est le
trafic des hommes et on ESS toute la
communaité européenne de se prendre la
main dans la main depuis lundi on
travaille tous en collaboration pour
lutter efficacement contre ces passeurs
lordinaire la Comé euréne oui dire qu'
on est en à la frontière avec l'Italie
l'Italie la France travaillent ensemble
on est en avec toutes les autres
frontières tout le monde se donne la
main dans la main en opérationnel pour
pouvoir lutter efficacement contre ces
passeurs h moi ce que je voudrais dire
sur cette histoire de passeurs je pense
qu'on est absolument tous d'accord pour
dire que ce sont effectivement des
criminels qu'on met la vie des gens en
danger juste je voudrais dire qu'en
pratique c'est c'est un effet d'annonce
le fait qu'on cherche vraiment à lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs parce que
moi au quotidien j'ai des clients qui
sont sans papier qui se font Interpel
jamais jamais je n'ai vu un service
enquêteur enquêter et demander
véritablement aux personnes comment vous
êtes arrivver est-ce que c'est un
passeur qui vous a fait venir si jamais
vous dénoncez votre passeur alors on
vous donnera un titre de séjour ça
existe actuellement pour les réseaux de
proxtisme et ça commence à fonctionner
effectivement pour les
PR r on a des brigades spécialisé qui
travaillent pour lut contre ce crime
organisé alors il est sûr que quand on
attrape un individu c'est pas notre
priorité pour lui dire tu es venu
comment et cetera mais on sait déjà
comment ça
fonctionne ça nexiste pas
malheureusement qu'à l'étranger ou pour
faire rentrer moi dans le cadre de l'un
de mes rapports je suis allé à plusieurs
reprises dans des centres d'accueil des
immigrés il y en a un notamment plutôt
bien d'ailleurs dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris et les
responsabl du centre me disent vous avez
bien fait de venir c'est le jour je leur
dis c'est le jour de quoi de la soupe
c'est le jour de quoi dis c'est le jour
vous allez voir la camionnette chechenen
va arriver et vous avez alors on s'est
mis devant avec les responsables du
centre on a vu arriver une camionnette
il y a un type un seul euh qui descend
qui ouvre à l'arrière sont descendus 9
ou 10 personnes qui venaient vers le
centre pour faire l'enregistrement les
papiers de départ et cetera avant
d'aller en préfecture non non pardon de
vous dire le le type en question même
les responsables du cent disaient la
semaine dernière il en a amené 10 autres
la semaine d'avant il en a amené
inter pas fa ce nous
inér inér téléspectateur est-ce qu'il a
une politique efficace quelque part en
Europe contre ces
rése
aucune le deal que tout à l'heure enfin
il y a une politique elle n'est pas
efficace j'entends mais le le le deal
qui était suggéré tout à l'heure par
Maître Madeline c'està-dire l'idée de
dire on te donne des papiers si tu
donnes le réseau qui t'a fait rentrer ça
existe quelque part après tout c'est un
système comme de repenti d'une certaine
manire j'imagine que ça doit exister
j'en ai pas officiellement connaissance
jeai jamais faire je n' je vous dis ça
existe pour les réseaux de prostitution
mais pas pour les réseaux d'immigration
CLAND c'est les gens ont
peur pas des enfants de cœur quand
même non plus il y a des fes qui parlent
donc je dis
pas on essaye même pas entre nous soit
dit on essae même pas pense pas il y a
quand même beaucoup de réseau de des
problèmes si je peux me permettre c'est
que chaque pays finalement gère tout
seul le flux d'immigrés qui Arve sur son
territoire au lieu de faire une alliance
européenne ou une union européne un vrai
problème de coopération et de solidarité
européenne sur cette question
aujourd'hui la politique européenne
d'immigration ça se limite pour au
contrôle et la surveillance des
frontières ça peut pas être l'alpha et
l'oméga d'une politique d'immigration
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
les pays du sud de l'Europe ont tout à
fait raison de se plaindre parce que
aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui doivent
faire face au plus grand afflux de
migrants simplement en raison de leur
position géographique sur la rive nord
Méditerranée l'Italie la Grèce Malte
l'Espagne ont raison de se plaindre ont
raison d'appeler une plus grande
coopération européenne et puis je pense
que fondamentalement un problème qu'on a
pas seulement en France mais en Europe
c'est qu'on considère toujours le
migrant comme une sorte de criminel en
pu et qu'on va chercher à arrêter les
migrants à forcoris s'ils sont dans des
situations irrégulières plutôt que de
viser les réseaux de passeurs que nous
créons nous-mêmes par cette politique de
plus en plus répressive c'est de plus en
plus difficile de venir par des voies
légales et donc les gens recourent à des
voies illégales et deviennent victime de
r certaine manière vous ouvririez les
frontières comme certains parlent de
légaliser le
cannabis frontièr supprimerait la
nécessité d' réseau de passeurs ça c'est
une évidence même sénateur Lena quand
vous AZ million d'immigr qui rentr dans
l'année il y aura pas besoin de passer
c'est là où connaissez la réalité de
l'immigration c'est d'imaginer que les
gens viendrai parce que les frontières
sont ouverts pas du tout les gens
viennent de toute façon il viendra
simplement dans de meilleures
condition plus parce que les situations
économiques n'étaient pas les mêmes
parce que les situations de né pas les
mêmes et parce que mais non mais c'est
vous qui dites n'importe quoi vous êtes
d' angélisme rare mais vous avez raison
de le penser puisque vous le pensez mais
la seule réalité c'est on sait bien que
la France et quelques autres pays
européens sont des pays entre guillemets
plus attirants plus attractifs la France
attire beaucoup moins d'étranger que
l'IR on est pour est là
pourbérien vous affffirmez votre
position vous pas du tout je donne les
chiffres de la France chné
200000our
mosalie on donne moins parce qu'on a une
politique migratoire plus ferme mais
c'est pas pour ça que si on ouvrait
complètement on aurait moins de gens qui
viendraementtiouvert pardon je par comme
comme on narrive pas à vous mettre
d'accord mais que chacun fait valoir ses
arguments on va en rester là sur ce
côté-là il y a un mot qui nous a frappé
en regardant le le documentaire et
peut-être vous également c'est le mot
mariage apparemment le mariage c'est une
clé d'entrer en France mariez-vous ce
serait l'arme fatale Jean Marie la loi
elle est bête c'estd que un jeune comme
vous ingénieur qui a un boulot il lu
donne pas ses papiers premier mariage
avec la première venue du moment que
c'est pas un mariage B il vous les donne
moi jeis vous je me marierez tout de
suite vous m'avez bien dit que vous
aviez une copine oui c'était sérieux
depuis longtemps ben oui bon ben
alorsors surtout que maintenant si vous
me dites qu'il y a des possibilités de
qu'il puisse être régularisé le problème
c'est qu'il faudrait qu'il ait des
buletins de salaire si vous vous mariez
ça c'est super parce
que après je sais qu'il faut pas se
marier pour ça mais des fois on a pas le
choix non plus quoi c'est ça
n parce que donc l'idéal ça aurait été
oui voulezv vous marier une fois qu'il a
ses papiers mais non mais je sais bien
c'est c'est toujours ce que me disent
les gens qui font des vrais mariages
d'amour ce qui veulent les papiers
d'abord avant le mariage et pas
l'inverse donc monsieur
voilà vous êtes donc libre vous pouvez
continuer votre relation amoureuse et si
vous voulez vous marier dépêchez-vous
oui finalement vous êtes une marieuse
maître un peu oui votre premier cons
c'est ça est est-ce que vous auriez une
petite amie ou un petit ami français à
épouser non mais c'est je comprends tout
à fait que ça puisse surprendre surtout
qu'on discute beaucoup de ces histoires
de mariage blanc de mariage gris je je
je comprends encore une fois que ça
puisse interpeller moi je suis avocat
les gens viennent me voir ils sont dans
une situation problématique et ils
attendent de moi des conseils il se
trouve que je dis la loi est bête de
manière un peu triviale ça se ça ferait
pas dire ça mais elle l'est de fait
puisque vous comparez par exemple une
personne qui vit en en concubinage
depuis 5 ou 6 ans avec un ressortissant
français juste un concubinage simple
devant la préfecture je n'arrive même
pas à déposer mon dossier c'est-à-dire
qu'on refusera même de m'instruire mon
dossier alors que vous avez une personne
qui arrive et qui se marie dans la
semaine de son arrivée en France avec un
français il est effectivement régularisé
de plein droit alors attention encore
une fois qu'on s'entende bien je ne dis
jamais à aucun de mes clients de faire
mariage de complaisance parce que c'est
extrêmement euh euh euh contrôlé il faut
savoir que quand on est ah oui oui quand
on est en situation irrégulière
maintenant et qu'on veut se marier je
peux vous dire qu'on a systématiquement
une enquête de la mairie une enquête du
procureur et de la police aux frontières
maintenant quasiment systématiquement et
qu'en plus pour avoir un droit permanent
au séjour il faut rester marié pendant 4
ans donc je peux vous dire que les
mariages blancs ça tient pas 4 ans mais
c'est vrai que je dire qu'il y en a plus
pour autant hein mais mon avis en a il
en a il y en a vraiment très pe parelqu
centaines vraiment il y en a pas non non
non il y en a plus il y en a ça a pu se
faire je pense ça à une époque où
effectivement quand on se mariait on
avait directement la carte de 10 ans
c'était relativement tant maintenant il
y a de tels contrôles que franchement ça
n'existe plus par contre c'est vrai que
je suis obligé de donner ce conseil
parce que légalement ça change ça
simplifie totalement votre situation je
crois que tout au début du documentaire
Joseph Mukendi répond à un monsieur
algérien qui dit je suis marié avec une
Française voilà et en fait le monsieur
appelle et dit je veux prendre un
rendez-vous avec vous et mon collègue
dit mais c'est même pas la peine de
prendre un rendez-vous aller directement
à la préfecture mais oui mais c'est la
loi et je heureusement qu'on protège
encore la liberté matrimoniale ça ça
fait parti ça vaut pour les enfants de
la même manière c'est est-ce que c'est
un pass pardon d'employer ces mots là
mais enfin c'est voilà est-ce que c'est
un passe aussi vers le vers une
régularisation d'avoir des enfants qui
naissent sur le territoire França qui na
sur le territoire
français qui na sur le territoire
français non alors là-dessus ça c'est
très bien que vous m'interrogiez parce
que je je je hurle devant ma télé à
longueur de temps quand vois des débats
politiques sur la question et certains
et certains hommes politiques qui
pourtant sont très bien documentés et
qui viennent dire oui il suffit de faire
un enfant sur le territoire français
pour être régularisé c'est complètement
faux il y a pas de droit du sol en
France il faut quand même le rappeler
parce que c'est dit à longueur de temp
un enfant qui naî sur le territoire
français n'est pas français peutir
français à l'âge de 18 ans il y a des
milliers y a des milliers sans papiers
qui ont des enfants en France et les
enfants ne sont pas français et les
parents n'ont pas de papiers donc on ne
fait pas d'enfant pour avoir des papiers
il donc on expulse aujourd'hui des
familles avec des enfants tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours et on
continue à mettre de temps en temps des
enfants dans les centres de rétention je
le dit aussi parce que on en parle moins
on a parlé de l'affaire leonarda c'est
ça que vous évoquiez en disant que
parfois on va même les les chercher à
l'école pour finir parce que c'est une
question très importante et que Manuel
Vals d'ailleurs avait créé une certaine
émotion comme ministre de l'Intérieur à
la à l'intérieur du gouvernement en en
en parlant la question du regroupement
familial c'est la principale porte
d'entrée en France pardon légal c'est ça
pour pour les immigrés c'est 90000
parents c'est aujourd'hui le motif
principal
d'entrée de délivrance des titres de
séjour legau en France à peu près 40 %
des titres de séjour donc à peu près
80000 sur 200000 sont délivrés pour des
raisons de regroupement familial en
effet et ça continuera parce que c'est
pratiquement le seul domaine qui est qui
est protégé en fait pour la bonne et
simple raison que par exemple le droit
au regroupement familial a été considéré
comme un principe à valeur
constitutionnelle donc on peut pas
revenir dessus Roger car il faut réunir
le Congrès donc l'Assemblée nationale et
les sénateurs pour revenir làdus de loi
qui qui reviendrait sur le regroupement
familial qui de mémoire n'existe que
depuis
74 avec
valcardestin si si bien entendu ça vous
ça vous SEM posé problème ça c'est pas
mais manuel Vals d'ailleurs on verra
bien ce qui est le texte définitif
puisqu'on ne l'a pas mais dans une ou
deux rencontres avec les parlementaires
avaient envisagé des limitations du
droit au regroupement familial
énormément limitation d'accord il faut
dire des limitations alors
supplémentaires comme ça c'est déjà un
droit qui est assez assz strict assez
restreint aujourd'hui il s'agit
essentiellement des enfants ou parents
ah non il a c'est pas les parents
attention le regroupement familial en
France ça n'est uniquement que le
conjoint et les enfant en c'est une
person par quand même ça n'existe que
chez nous ah non la plupart des P
européens c'est beaucoup plus ouvert
dans la plupart des autres pays
oui mais ça ça qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise j'aime bien quand on
regarde il faut tout regarder par
exemple aujourd'hui nous avons nous
75000 à peu près peut-être 80000 cette
année demandeurs
d'asile il y en a un peu plus chez par
exemple en Allemagne un peu moins chez
les autres il faut faire un bloc en
réalité et lorsque le bloc se regarde
c'est évident qu'on a un problème et que
que ce soit l'opinion publique que ce
soit la capacité de l'État que ce soit
le respect du droit il faudra bien
légiférer alors il y a un texte qui
vient sur sur l'immigration un texte qui
vient sur le droit d'asile il y aura un
débat parlementaire serré et où par
définition gauche- droite nous allons
durcir les condition je vous laisse en
juger de l'autre côté de votre
téléviseur ou en tout cas de votre écran
merci à à tous d'en avoir débattu
parfois vivement mais en essayant
d'apporter des informations c'est ce qui
comptait vous pouvez continuer à à
commenter cette émission sur notre
adresse mail qui s'inscrit comme
d'habitude en bas de votre écran la
semaine prochaine pas de débat mais un
docu un documentaire ou plutôt la
première partie d'une série formidable
sur les asiatiques de France à très vite
sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat